l aget i ragazzi e ben vedere questo
video oggi siamo suo qv mapper nei tre
no clan traumi anche se tu fai il
videogioco pensa devi fare non solo in
russo che non parlo neanche di italiano
io avevo già è un gioco sui clown in
teoria auto save ok anno questa era
carica partita bene nuova partita gli
attrezzi un pro class che in iraq alguer
scritte hybrid ok lune 37 meno male che
allora non iscritte al russo anche se
effettivamente non cambia niente per
spacconi noci e non e 37 qualcuno ha
bussato alla porta va bene perché in
russia terra de rossi ea tv sarà la
quarta al 137 per mese per mese boris
rivale forte chi essere ricevuti
invadiamo e polonia dove purchia bussate
jazz de mer de rossi e in terra del
rossi a farlo buone pizza né a marco
italia frena il coltello che difendere
chi ha bussato mia porta senza vodka non
ho capito che ha bussato alla porta però
si tratta di clown quindi ci saranno dei
clan
comunque non ho ancora capito dove siamo
che avrà quebec condominio che questo 5
stelle previene taratura gli articoli
simo tra piccoli e romano non ho capito
c'è una risibile siamo in shining
centri ciclo di shining fantastico
permesso questa questa porta vera di
terra del ruggiero cane de rossi ha
promesso semi spuntano altri nani
dalmazzo vabbè normale che luminoso di
da perfetto anche di quattromiglia
fantastico posso salire sulla scala no
posso usare all'assessore delle chiavi
what a grazie alle a chiarissimo bene
sicuro che sarà questa è troppo
illuminata vai fra chi è forse prima
doveva suonare perché si usa a suonare
il campanello permesso qualcuno no che
figo cubo di rubik
c'è già è arrivata la notifica su
facebook di a lasciare incustodito il
telefono ma ti fotto tutta la rubrica o
poi tra brevi et russia né terra erano
sia bello il video lasciate mi piace su
tutto questo lasciare mi piace siano sì
ho detto a napoli gioca bene come the
moment
il trainer gli spieghi perché iscrivi le
cose in russo e poi la segreteria
telefonica inglese ma che problemi hai
ancora non ho capito se youtube non e
youtube
ce lo lascio like bikers
belli insieme così che rimorchi la [ __ ]
è questo che è passato prima di michael
cattani ciao michael kata neve cosa e
massimo boldi con vestito da clown
questa roba
sa che tra l'altro è sul comodino
fantastico degli snow internet
connection porca vacca che sfiga o alla
fibra manca la fibra in russia qua c'era
un cenno un clown pin sia aperto
l'ascensore di sotto perché si è aperto
l'ascensore qui vai chiudi non so non so
cosa ho obbligato ma ok
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no mi servirebbe un coltello non lo
puoi usarlo un coltello ma marzo è
cascato nell'ascensore cascato giù o
salve senta signor boldi
io ho visto tutti i film di natale a in
egitto quindi non mi faccia del male
perché sono una bella persona
se sta roba allora andiamo con questa
sinistra non ti devi incazzare zero cioè
hai capito la giusta calma acquisto e
per salvare la partita ok quindi esci lo
salva bene allora continua
tanto tempo per capire un menù è bello
mi sono svegliato qua mi ha portato qua
il clown giorno fantastico
sempre meglio di dove mi sono svegliato
all'inizio del gioco uscita uscita c'è
scritto uscita e invece non si esce
che bello non ti prendono per il culo
così non vedo una sega un altro uscito
wow come come so che già anche questa
uscita ma servirà un cazzo permesso o la
lanterna che figata
le pastiglie da mettere nel culo bene
ragazzi erano la lanterna è questa qui
c'e una cosa su per meglio del coltello
vista del controllo xi ma se c'è uscita
prova almeno uscirne o niente non
trovare sempre di jolo jolo a me
piacciono i clown
deve succedere tipo it che adesso
diventa sangue
no a lo prendo proprio ora che figata
con le finali palloncini c'è questo
gioco è fatto di merda però la dinamica
di palloncini e fatta da dio
com'è possibile c'è in russia sono
esperti a programmare la fisica dei
palloncini solo
adesso sì che questo è un posto allegro
autentico di vista pin ma c'era prima
sta roba
c'era non c'era e satana sia dalla tua
parte non dalla mia miscredente che
bello che sei che ci hai una notte al
posto dei capelli ma è cambiato con al
quadro poi prendete per il culo tra temi
più per il culo e chi è che ha cambiato
il quadro bello tra l'altro molto più ve
lo dico di prima non troppo a questo è
il bar il bar farmi entrare al bar
permesso non per alcolisti ma allora
niente
io chi la guarda di oakhill a parte zio
non si chiude dio low cost a un altro
clown
non sembra voler vivere vivere mi veniva
da lui ma da lui non si chiude niente
qua giochiamo al gioco dell'impiccato
che sono bravo york a [ __ ] motori
plateau non so come ladri lato non so
come vai ed efficiente meno male ed
efficiente come ho fatto a dribblarlo
non ho capito neanche io va bene va bene
o dribblato un clown caso questo non so
come ho fatto a prendere un infarto ma
ci sono andato decisamente vicino mi
dite esattamente dove dovrei andare per
aprire cioè qual è la porta che si apre
questa chiave avrò il bar perfetto
entriamo al bar mai così chiudi chiudi
chiudi clip perfetto noi esce sanchez al
tipo belle queste vasche come me la
farei volentieri una doccia qua bull
salve buon salve
beh bello minchia che selphy tutti in
famiglia è demo a demo affida a demo
rick ross con i anche damon fantastico a
poco uscito il gioco pieno di
significato ragazzo bellissimo ogni
volta che trovo videogiochi dove ci sono
i clown è fantastico perché qualche
bello ma che sbaglia che che pezzo
tesoro
ragazzi io concludo più il video vi
ringrazio per consigliarvi sempre questa
roba perché questo accada vieta le mie
giornate poi questi tipi di giochi sono
ciò di cui ho bisogno
grazie ragazzi che avete capito i miei
bisogni grazie mille quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come senso che
più di un momento è un mi piace anche ai
vari social come descrizione so se
rischiate lì ci rivediamo il prossimo
video speriamo senza clown perché sono
una miglia bella è bella
non so vabbè previene riviera
[Musica]